it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd
and sunscreen connoisseur i've had a lot
of people ask me to explain the nitty
gritty behind how sunscreen ingredients
work
and i warned everyone it would be super
nerdy and really quite complicated
but you all said it was fine so here it
is
the fine details the deep dive into how
sunscreen ingredients work
if you're more interested in finding a
sunscreen that works for you this is
probably not the right video
i have a whole playlist of sunscreen
videos that i've linked in the
description as well
now don't freak out but this is physical
chemistry it is
upper high school slash undergraduate
level chemistry
i'm going to try to explain it very
simply so you should be able to follow
it even if you don't remember
anything from chemistry in school i also
have a written version of this linked in
the video description
so if you prefer to learn by reading or
if you zone out and you don't know
what's going on
have a look at that as always if you
like talking about the science behind
beauty products click the like the
subscribe and the notification bell so
you don't miss any videos
[Music]
as you all hopefully know sunscreens
contain active ingredients that reduce
the amount of uv hitting your skin
remember that uv
is a type of light it's higher energy
and shorter wavelength than visible
light
and there are two types of uv that we
care about because that's what hits our
skin from the sun
uvb which is higher energy shorter
wavelength and uva which is
lower energy longer wavelength the
shorter the wavelength the higher the
energy
there are two main categories of
sunscreen ingredients organic and
inorganic which is sometimes called
chemical and physical even though those
aren't really good descriptors
organic sunscreens are the ones with
complicated names and they contain lots
of carbon atoms joined together
inorganic sunscreens which are sometimes
called mineral sunscreens
are zinc oxide and titanium dioxide i
talk about which ones you should choose
in my chemical versus physical sunscreen
videos so if you're more interested in
the applications of sunscreen
check that one out
[Music]
i'm going to start by talking about how
organic sunscreen ingredients work
overall what they do is absorb uv energy
and then convert it to more harmless
forms of energy mostly heat
the law of conservation of energy says
that you can't create or destroy
energy you can only convert it to other
forms so that's exactly what these
sunscreen molecules do
they're like little factories that take
in the uv energy and convert it to
something that isn't going to make your
skin massively age or give you cancer
the way that they do this is with
electrons
chemicals all have electrons inside them
and these electrons depending on which
chemical they're in
can absorb different types of energy and
convert it into other forms
so you can imagine that your sunscreen
molecule is sitting on your skin
it's very low energy it's very stable
it's perfectly happy sitting there
now if the right type of uv light comes
along the right wavelength
the electrons in that sunscreen molecule
can absorb that uv
so now it's taken in some energy that
sunscreen molecule is very excited
so it was down here now it's up here and
it's very energetic
excited is actually the technical term
for this
things don't like to have a lot of
energy so this sunscreen molecule isn't
very
stable it wants to get rid of that
energy and go back to where it was
before
so the electrons in that sunscreen
molecule convert that energy to
something else
and poop it out the sunscreen goes back
to
where it was before this is called
relaxation again it is a technical term
now that it's back in its lower energy
form it's free to absorb more uv
and then convert that to something else
and this can happen again and again
this is actually a similar process to
why black things get hot in the sun
black dye is really good at absorbing
visible light and so it absorbs that
light the electrons in it get excited
and then it releases that energy back
out as heat
fireworks also work this way so the
electrons and fireworks
absorb the heat energy from the
explosives and then it releases that
energy back out as light
that's actually why we have different
colors there are different chemicals
inside the fireworks which release
different colors of light
now you might be wondering what sorts of
energy do sunscreen molecules release
then
it depends on which sunscreen chemical
you're talking about but it is usually a
combination of different types of energy
it can be vibrations which turn into
heat as those vibrations knock into
other molecules and those vibrations get
passed on
heat is really just vibrations it can be
lower energy forms of light so remember
you can't create energy out of nothing
so that sunscreen molecule might convert
part of the uv into a lower energy form
of light and the rest of it into heat
sunscreens can release infrared
radiation which turns into heat in your
skin
visible light or even lower energy forms
of uv
the uv can also turn into chemical
energy and what that means
is breaking bonds sometimes this is
reversible so the sunscreen molecule can
keep working
so the bond breaks and unbreaks as it
converts the uv energy into chemical
energy
just like we talked about before but
sometimes it's not reversible so that
means you don't get your original
molecule back
so your sunscreen slowly decomposes and
stops working over time
this is what happens when a sunscreen is
photo unstable
when formulators try to make a sunscreen
ingredient more photostable
basically what they're doing is trying
to convince that molecule to convert the
uv
energy into other forms of energy rather
than breaking the irreversible bonds
so with all this talk of heat you might
be wondering does your skin
heat up the answer is maybe a tiny bit
but the amount of heat is
tiny compared to the amount that you're
getting from other things
if you're wearing sunscreen and you can
feel your skin get hot in the sun
it's probably not the sunscreen in the
uv it's probably the infrared light and
the visible light turning into heat in
your skin
sunlight is only about three to seven
percent uv compared to 44
visible light and 53 infrared your skin
also might be irritated by the sunscreen
which can make it go hot
but it's almost definitely not the uv
you're feeling if you do the conversion
your skin temperature might go up by
less than one degree there's probably a
bigger difference between this part of
your arm and this part of your arm right
now
[Music]
so organic sunscreen molecules absorb uv
but why do some of them absorb uva and
some of them absorb uvb
and some of them absorb both let's have
a look at their structures
the first thing you'll notice is
probably that a lot of them have
rings these are pentagons and hexagons
they also have this pattern of having a
double bond then a single bond then a
double bond
sometimes it's in rings sometimes it's
not and this is called conjugation
conjugation gives the electrons in the
molecule a special property which is
that they can run around a bit
this is called delocalization the bigger
your conjugated pattern
the more delocalized these electrons are
so they can run around more
and they can absorb smaller amounts of
energy by default if you have a molecule
with no conjugation
it can probably only absorb uvc in other
words the energy gap
between the lower level and the higher
level matches the uvc
range this is completely useless for us
because uvc doesn't reach us on earth
if it's a smaller molecule with
conjugation then this gap gets a bit
smaller and it goes into the uvb
range if the conjugated pattern gets
bigger then this gap gets even smaller
and we get into the uva range
so you'll notice that the uvb filters
tend to be a bit smaller than the uva
filters
if you have rings you also get more
delocalization which is why you see all
these rings in sunscreen chemicals
if you make this gap even smaller then
it's going to absorb visible light and
this is actually how you get
dyes if you look at dye molecules these
absorb some of the visible light
and the rest of the color bounces into
your eye and so you see it as a color
so this is acid violet 43 which is
what's currently in my hair
it absorbs yellow and so you see it as
purple so apart from conjugation
other things on the sunscreen molecule
can also change the amount of
delocalization
oxygen and nitrogen atoms can add extra
electrons so this extends how far the
electrons can run
if atoms on the molecule can interact
with other atoms and form rings this
also increases the area where these
electrons can run
so for example let's look at avobenzone
avobenzone has two forms and these can
turn into each other
if you look at the conjugation pattern
this one has a much smaller one you can
see that it breaks in the middle where
we have two single bonds next to each
other
but in this version we have a much
bigger pattern it pretty much takes
up the whole molecule so this version
which has less delocalization absorbs a
shorter wavelength
this one which has a bigger
delocalization pattern absorbs a longer
wavelength
this whole idea where the wavelength of
uv that a particular sunscreen molecule
absorbs is linked to the amount of
delocalization
also explains a lot of the things that
people keep on saying about the
importance of the formula
for example if you have an acidic filter
at a high ph
it gets a negative charge this means
that there's more
electrons more delocalization so it will
absorb a longer wavelength
if you have a basic filter these usually
have nitrogens on their structure
if you put them at a low ph they'll
actually get a positive charge
and this shortens the amount of space
that the electrons have to run around
and so they'll absorb a shorter
wavelength solvents can also interact
with either the lower state or the
higher state and this will
lower their energy if the solvent
interacts with the lower state that's
called the ground state
that lower state will decrease in energy
and so that gap
gets bigger that means that the
sunscreen molecule will absorb
higher energy uv a shorter wavelength if
it interacts with the top state the
excited state then that will get lower
and so
now you get a smaller gap it will absorb
lower energy
longer wavelength for octanoxate its
main uv absorbance can actually change
by 20 nanometers just by changing the
[Music]
solvent
so let's ungracefully switch for a
moment to these graphs that you might
have been seeing around
each line shows the uv absorbance for a
specific sunscreen ingredient i'm going
to get rid of
everything except avobenzone for a
moment the way we read this graph
is the horizontal axis is the wavelength
as we go from left to right the
wavelength gets longer and so we're
going from
higher energy uvb to lower energy uva
the vertical line is absorbance and so
the higher the line is the more of that
wavelength it's absorbing
so avobenzone absorbs some uvb it
absorbs a bit more uva
it reaches a maximum at 357 nanometers
so it's absorbing the most there
then it drops down again as we keep on
going through the uva region
that's why we call it a uva filter it
does absorb a bit of uvb but it mostly
absorbs uva
a broad spectrum ingredient means that
it absorbs more wavelengths and so
you'll see
a fatter chunkier curve tendonosol s's
curve for example looks like this
so it absorbs both uva and uvb it is a
broad spectrum filter
now you might be wondering if a
sunscreen molecule absorbs uv that
matches the energy gap
and we only have one sunscreen
ingredient why is it absorbing all these
wavelengths shouldn't it just absorb one
single wavelength shouldn't we get a uv
dot rather than a uv curve why is it
absorbing 357
and 360 and 350 nanometers why isn't it
just absorbing one
single wavelength that's because in real
life molecules move around
and in a single drop of sunscreen you
have billions and billions and billions
and billions of sunscreen molecules
so there'll be billions that look like
this and like this and like this and
like this
and all of these will have slightly
different delocalization and so they all
have slightly different energy gaps
and so all of them will absorb slightly
different wavelengths so the energy gap
diagram actually looks a bit more like
this
there are lots of different energy gaps
possible and some of these are more
likely to happen than others
so there's more of the 357 nanometer
transition there's less of the 350 less
of the 340 and so on
and this happens with every sunscreen
ingredient which is why we get lots of
different curves rather
than lots of dots all of these molecules
absorb lots of different wavelengths in
different amounts
now some of these curves are a bit more
complicated so chinosorb s
for example it has a double hum it's
because it actually has
two overlapping humps tennis obs and a
lot of the newer sunscreen filters as
well as some of the older ones
have more complicated structures so if
you look at their delocalization systems
they look a bit more 2d rather than 1d
they look more like
a shape rather than just a line so
there's more than one possible
electronic transition that can happen
there's one in the uva
and one in the uvb region both of these
transitions are again a bit fuzzy and so
again you get two curves rather than
two dots now if we look at the curves of
different sunscreen filters you'll see
that some of these are higher and some
of these are lower
the higher the line the more it absorbs
in that particular wavelength
so if it's high in the uvb it absorbs
uvb more strongly
if it's higher in the uva it absorbs uva
more strongly
these are all comparing the same mass
concentration of the sunscreen they're
all one percent
in ethanol so this is very roughly
reflected
in the actives in an actual sunscreen
product but you do have to remember that
these curves don't completely reflect
what happens in a sunscreen product
these are for the sunscreen filters
dissolved in ethanol
when you actually put a sunscreen on
your skin the ethanol evaporates pretty
quickly
the sunscreen also dries down into a
film rather than floating around
in liquid which is what's happening in
these curves and so that also changes
the optical properties of the film
and remember there are also lots of
things like ph and solvent that could
change
those energy gaps and so that means that
the curve might shift to the left might
shift to the right
might shift up and down a bit it gets
even more complicated if you put more
than one filter into a single sunscreen
if you have a uvb filter and a uva
filter then having them both in there
means that you can get a broad spectrum
curve
so that means for the overall sunscreen
the final curve
will look very different from these
it'll be sort of like you add them
together
when i say add together i don't mean you
can just sum them up the final curve can
be a bit tricky to predict
the filters might interact
synergistically so the curve ends up
higher than you'd expect
they might change each other's
delocalization and so the curve might
shift left and right there's lots and
lots of possibilities that you can't
really predict
again these curves are for one percent
in a solution not
whatever percentage in your actual
sunscreen product if you have a higher
percentage the curve will go up because
you have more sunscreen molecules on
your skin
the sunscreen molecules can absorb more
uv and so you have
higher absorbance another thing to
notice is that it doesn't matter how
many filters you have to build that
final curve
what matters is just that final curve
i've seen some skin care science
influencers say that you need more
filters for redundancy but that's not
how uv absorbance works
it's like saying that a 2 meter ladder
made of steel aluminium and wood
will get you higher than a two meter
ladder just made of steel
they both get you two meters it doesn't
matter what materials they're made of
[Music]
now to the inorganic sunscreen zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide
back in the day the cosmetics industry
thought that they worked just by
scattering uv
it was actually written into the 1978
fda legislation and then taken out when
they revised it in 1999
so that's probably why this is so
widespread but scientists have known
that it works by mostly absorbing uv
for quite a long time and scientists
keep pointing it out in peer-reviewed
papers but it's just one of those myths
that
won't die the way that zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide work
is very much like an organic sunscreen
so they have
electrons that can absorb uv and get
excited into a higher state
then when those electrons relax back
down that uv energy converts to more
harmless forms
so heat or light or lower energy uv
or infrared but zinc oxide and titanium
dioxide are
inorganic that means they don't have
carbon atoms in their structure
so they don't have the same ability to
make conjugated systems
instead what they have is called a
bandgap structure
so here is what zinc oxide looks like
there are a lot of atoms packed closely
together which means lots of electrons
and so those electrons can interact with
each other so we get lots and lots of
different energy levels for lots of
different electrons
so instead of a low energy level and a
high energy level you have
a low energy band made up of lots of
levels
and a high energy band made up of lots
of levels the smallest gap between them
from the highest low energy level
to the lowest high energy level is
the minimum absorbance so the smallest
energy gap that can be absorbed
so that's the minimum energy or longest
wavelength they can absorb
and they can absorb pretty much every uv
energy level higher than this so every
shorter wavelength of uv
and that's because of that band
structure the fact there's so many
different levels there's lots of
different energy transitions that can
happen
so that's why the absorbance curves look
like they suddenly go off a cliff
that cliff matches the shortest energy
gap
now this absorbance explains about 95 of
how they work
the other approximately 5 is scattering
scattering is when the uv comes in and
the particle changes the direction that
it's going in
it doesn't actually usually bounce
backward it usually bounces forwards
so it keeps on going but at a different
angle so a lot of the time uv light
actually gets scattered towards your
skin
which is actually okay because it means
that it takes a longer path it's not
taking the shortest path anymore
and that means there's a higher chance
of that uv hitting another particle and
getting absorbed
now inorganic sunscreens are pretty
complicated because you can get
different particle sizes
in sunscreens the particle size is
usually really small less than 200
nanometers
that's because scattering is
proportional to diameter the bigger it
is the more it scatters the less it
absorbs
it's not only uv that gets scattered
it's also visible light and so the
larger the particle
the more scattering you get the more
visible light gets scattered into your
eye from the sunscreen
and you see it as a white cast there's
also the fact that only atoms at the
surface of the particle can absorb uv
if you have a big particle and you break
it down into smaller particles you get
more surface exposed and so you get
greater uv
absorbance longer wavelengths also get
scattered more than shorter wavelengths
so
even though the particles are mostly
absorbing the uv
they can also at the same time be
scattering visible light zinc oxide
absorbs both uva and uvb
titanium dioxide mostly absorbs uvb and
mostly scatters uva
but it does depend on the particular
particle size of the sunscreen
i'm going to leave it there if you got
to this point congratulations well done
i am very proud here is your prize the
cutest thing i've seen in a long time
these two penguins both had their
partners pass away but
every night they meet up to watch the
city lights and comfort each other for
hours
if you have any questions drop them down
below and i'll try my best to answer
them
if you like the video click the like and
subscribe you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin beauty science
and check out my blog for more nerdy
beauty content
see you next time to nerd out more